[Music]
nico robin is a special character in the
story of one piece i've always felt
deeply intrigued by her personality
because her actions invoke a series of
emotions and thoughts in me like no one
else in the story does as if there was
something about her character that was
speaking to me on a level that my mind
wasn't really expecting from a story
like one piece a sense of destiny and
importance that usually is reserved for
no one less than the protagonist or
maybe the antagonist
despite being one of the main characters
of the series and holding a unique
position in the world robin somehow
always manages to stay in the background
shrouding herself and her thoughts in
deep mystery as a result there are
several reasons why i found the epithet
of lightbringer so incredibly fitting
for her character
lightbringer is the literal translation
of lucifer an angel fallen from god's
grace or in other words the devil as the
sole survivor of the genocide on the
island of o'hara throughout her life
robin has been marked as the devil child
an attempt by the world government to
silence and discredit her because
robin's knowledge and interest in the
history of the world is one of the if
not the biggest threat to the world
government
being the only person left in the world
that can decipher the language of the
ancient kingdom she's the only person
capable of learning the truth about the
void century but while knowledge of the
true history is something that the
gorosei and emo want to keep buried the
polyglyphs hold the key to even greater
threats namely information on the three
ancient weapons that are capable of
waging a war on a global scale and the
location of the final island in the
grand line raftel that is closely
connected to the birth of a new pirate
king in other words robin is the key to
everything that is a real threat to the
system of power that the world
government has established the only
person in the world that can bring
destruction and chaos to the world order
they have built for the past 900 years
it is no wonder then that robin is seen
as the devil of the one piece world the
person capable of breaking the wheel if
you want good thing robin doesn't have a
dragon though
ironically enough though all these
reasons have also led to robin's second
epithet the light of the revolution her
unique skills and positioning in the
world have become a source of hope in
the opposition to the world government
the revolutionaries without her the
world will most likely never be changed
so while robin is the lucifer to the
world government she is also the light
of hope for the revolutionaries fighting
for a better world i think calling robin
the lightbringer reflects really well on
her character being a two-sided coin
since we have no real idea of what robin
already knows about the world and how
she plans on using that knowledge she is
a real wild card in the story that could
get grave importance again at any moment
combined with her calm and quiet
personality i think it's fair to say
that maybe next to zorro she's the most
mysterious of the straw hats since there
is so little we truly know about her so
who is robin and what makes her
characters so unique in the story of one
piece
the way we got introduced to robin was
very different from anything we had
gotten for any of the other straw hats
up to that point robin was a mysterious
and immensely interesting antagonist of
the straw hats during the baroque work
arc her contradictive actions helping
the straw heads in some ways while then
opposing them again in others led to a
quick fascination with a character for
me
only slowly do we learn that robin only
joined forces with the warlock crocodile
to follow her own ambitions
the image we get of her is that of a
ruthless assassin that used any means
necessary to get what she wants
so despite luffy's kindness towards her
it was a true twist in the story when
she suddenly appeared on the ship
inviting herself to join the crew in
retrospect however i think it makes a
lot of sense that luffy saved and
accepted robin on his ship because as we
learned from rayleigh during the time
skip luffy has the ability to sense a
person's true intentions so while luffy
was already aware of robin's true nature
it took us a whole lot more to truly
understand robin's character and
motivations and i dare say that this
process led to some of the best arcs in
the story the timing and pace that oda
used to place nico robin in the story
was simply amazing when looking at the
story up until the time skip having a
mysterious and complex antagonist with a
cool and dark vibe turn into an ally and
then slowly revealing the history and
impact of that character everything
about this character introduced a new
level of complexity and heaviness to the
story that didn't really exist up to
that point
robin's past the genocide of her people
her life-long run from the grasp of the
world government and the loneliness and
heartbreak she experienced really
hammered in what one piece was going to
be about in the long run with robin we
were introduced to the poneglyphs and
with them to the mystery of the ancient
kingdom its weapons and the source of
injustice in the world with the
introduction of the cp9 we were shown
the cruelty and ruthlessness with which
the world government operated and how
corrupt and unjust the entire system
truly was
with robin one piece changed its nature
and scale of complexity it went from a
young boy trying to find the ultimate
treasure in the world of pirates
together with his friends to a political
and complex story about healing the
world and breaking the unjust and cruel
system under which the world is
suffering robin as a character is
constructed in a way that mirrors
everything that is wrong with the
current system when she joins the crew
her greatest weaknesses are her deep
lack of trust in anyone but herself a
great lack of self-confidence and
self-worth and a strong sense of
loneliness and isolation
all these things can easily be tracked
back to her past while she had already
been tormented by her uncle and his wife
and feared by the other children for her
devil fruit powers it took the entire
cruelty of the world government to rob
young robin from all her positivity and
hope first her mother and everyone she
knew were murdered in front of her eyes
then they brainwashed the public into
believing that robin was the last
survivor of a group that was trying to
destroy the world by finding the ancient
weapons they robbed her of any chance of
refuge or care so robin had to grow up
on her own hiding and on the run
as a result robin has a clear moral
problem that her character needs to
solve her inability to trust and open up
to others keeps her from following the
path she actually wants to go to learn
and to live in peace while she's
actually a very kind-hearted and caring
person her tragic past has forced her to
put up a wall around herself that keeps
her from making any friends and since
she doesn't trust anyone she ends up
hurting those around her as well by
manipulating and using them for her own
interests when she's taken by the cp9
even though she already wants to protect
the crew her inability to share her
thoughts and feelings with others end up
hurting her friends the big challenge
for robin's character was therefore to
overcome this wall that she had built
around herself and once again allow
herself to open up and trust others
on the surface at first glance robin's
dream doesn't really seem to be
connected to this need her dream is to
learn the true history of the world and
uncover what was lost and hidden given
her heritage of o'hara and her passion
for archaeology this of course makes
sense and i hope you agree with me when
i say that robin's dream is a lot more
relevant to the actual plot than some of
the other straw hats compared to brook
or sanji for example whose dreams are
more personal robin's dream is directly
connected to opposing the strongest
political and military force on the
planet her dream goes hand in hand with
reaching raftel and making luffy the
pirate king i had a real click moment in
my head when i saw how perfectly that
dream fit in with her character but
going back to her moral problem robin
also has a second dream that is actually
on a more personal level robin wants to
find someone to protect and in that
sense she is already in the unique
position where she's aware of a moral
problem something that usually takes a
very impactful event to uncover in
robin's case though it simply shows us
how deep her vulnerability really goes
even though she knows that she wants to
love and trust people she has suffered
too much to overcome it herself both of
these dreams also go really well hand in
hand with the values that robin holds as
we keep learning over the course of the
story robin is a much more positive
person than she appears in the beginning
she actually strongly values trust
kindness and relationships in general
her twisted sense of humor seems to be a
result of these ideals and the harsh
reality she had to live in being a woman
of science similar to chopper she also
highly values knowledge and the way it
is used also as you know being the most
political amongst the crew robin clearly
values peace which is why we can see
robin at her happiest when she's reading
a book on board of the ship out at sea
most importantly though robin finally
learns to value life not only life of
others but especially her own which is
one of the greatest moral messages of
oda in the entire story i feel because
being able to love yourself for who you
are is probably the most important
factor in growing as a person and
finding happiness
based on these values and her past robin
is an incredibly intelligent and
knowledgeable character being at the
center of political interest she
probably has the most realistic and
complete view of the world in the crew
and having to survive all this time by
herself she has learned to play smart
and also dirty if necessary together
with her calm and collected manner and
her for me personally hilarious dark
humor i would say that she has developed
a really strong personality and since
she plays such an important role in the
story robin of course has also gathered
a number of powerful opponents that only
maybe luffy can come close to being on
the top wanted list of the world
government and all its organizations
robin has enemies all over the world
including the citizens
additionally pirates and other
organizations also crave her skills
putting her at danger anywhere she goes
to best illustrate how all of these
factors come together in the story let's
now take a look at robin's character arc
i think that it will not come as a big
surprise to you when i tell you that
robin's main character arc took place
over the course of two major arcs the
baroque work saga and the water 7 and
anna's lobby arc first being introduced
as an antagonist we got to know of robin
stark and mysterious side basically the
result of her tragic past her character
only begins to truly change though when
she's rescued by luffy from the tomb in
alabasta upon deciding to join the crew
since she has nowhere else to go robin
slowly starts to experience friendship
and kindness as she hasn't since she met
saul on o'hara she was slowly accepted
by the crew and even though she didn't
truly feel like a part of them she still
learned to appreciate this new and
positive environment she found herself
in so after simply being a normal part
of the crew for the entirety of the
skypia arc robin started to feel
connected to the crew a moral problem
and lack of self-confidence though led
her to leave the crew behind to protect
them from the influence of the world
government she wanted to shield the
straw hats from the greatest scheme of
things and keep them out of the world of
politics and save from any prosecution
by oda making anna's lobby into a major
developing arc for the entire crew
though he made the message to robin even
more powerful her friends would not only
stand behind her but overcome their
limits and become stronger just for her
sake they were prepared to take on the
biggest power in the world just for her
luffy did not simply put her above his
interests he made her part of them the
entirety of the innis lobby arc is
simply amazing how oda was able to bring
together so many different elements and
push the story in so many ways all by
creating robin the way she is
so when she sees how important she
actually is to others she is finally
able to overcome an inability to put
trust and hope into others and opens
herself up to the straw hats i think
that it's no surprise then that this
moment is one of the most impactful ones
in the entire story
at the same time robin is also able to
achieve one of her dreams and has
finally found someone she can protect
and care for she was truly able to
challenge her basic beliefs and in the
end managed to overcome her weaknesses
and break down her wall i can say with
confidence that robin's character arc up
until the time skip is one of my
favorite ones in fiction
so if you watched my video on chopper
you probably know what is coming now
because same as chopper i feel like
robin's character has a big problem
because in more than just one way her
character arc has already finished by
the time skip and i do not complain
about that as i just said i believe her
arc was simply incredible and greatly
set up by oda the problem is that i
don't see anything new happening with
robin
similar to chopper she has also lost her
mysterious and cool vibe and has now
become someone with a funny hat that
keeps in the background most of the time
and smiles a lot it sometimes literally
feels like oda has sucked all excitement
out of this amazing character and
especially in robin's case i feel that
that is such a waste because her
character is so complex and has so many
sides that there was more than one
option to keep robin relevant and
fascinating isn't her character
interesting enough to serve as more than
just a technical piece in reaching
raftel and learning the truth because
even though robin has changed the fact
that she's still one of the most
notoriously wanted people in the world
shouldn't have changed robin has so many
capabilities and yet never has played
any major role in any arc since the time
skip she is so well versed in the
political structures of the world and
was part of the underworld herself and
yet in dressrosa as well as in whole
cake island where the underworld and
political structures played such a big
role she didn't play any and apart from
that robin has one of the most amazing
devil fruits in the story she could
literally spy on anyone by creating eyes
anywhere she can create clones but only
uses them in very limited ways she could
maybe create additional muscles to power
up her physical strength but how in the
world does it fit her smart and witty
character that she decided to use her
fruit to make giant arms and legs that
aimlessly stomp around isn't that rather
something that a luffy or a frankie
would do with all the opportunities this
fruit has especially for her character
outside and inside of combat this power
could be used so much smarter even
though i think her character change was
handled amazingly i don't think that
overcoming her weaknesses and finding
friends necessarily had to mean turning
her into a playing character why not
keep her edge and sinister vibe for a
bit her smooth confident attractive and
dangerous personality is gone and she is
now easily overshadowed by strong
personalities like luffy zorro or even
usop now don't get me wrong as we have
established before robin still has to
play an important role in the story we
pretty much don't know what she was up
to with the revolutionaries during the
time skip and she might very well still
keep her secrets she will play a
decisive role in tumbling the world
government and maybe even in creating a
new and just world order but i still
wish that oda would have left some of
the fascination in her character and
gave her some new character arc in the
new world because robin is the
lightbringer the devil for the world
government and the light of the
revolution and i think both of these
roles deserve a little bit more
attention and development
and maybe a new leather jacket